bonjour et bienvenue au coeur du
parlement européen nous sommes cette
semaine à strasbourg où les députés
siègent en séance plénière mais on
entend d'ailleurs parfois la sonnerie
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission nous avons rendez vous avec
josé bové pour parler des aoc et du
nouveau label européen aop nous irons
dans une exploitation franc comtoise qui
souffrent de cette réforme
mais d'abord on commence par l'actualité
avec la belgique qui inquiète ses
partenaires européens
l'hymne national flamand pourrait-il
bientôt devenir l'hymne d'une flandre
indépendante après la victoire écrasante
du nva la nouvelle alliance flamande et
de son leader bart de wever l'hypothèse
gagne du terrain
le 13 juin dernier 30% des électeurs de
flandre ont voté pour ce parti qui
prévoit selon son leader
une évaporation progressive de la
belgique le pays doit être réformé les
finances assainies
c'est pourquoi nous devons être unis en
tant que flamand pour réussir à changer
le pays
en wallonie terre francophone s'est en
revanche le leader socialiste elio di
rupo qui l'a emporté nord et sud se
retrouvent dos à dos le paysage
politique belge est plus éclaté que
jamais les tractations pour un nouveau
gouvernement ne font que commencer
bart de wever figure désormais
incontournable ne veut pas d'un titre de
premier ministre dans un royaume dont il
conteste l'existence même dès le
lendemain des élections il a donc
quasiment offert ce poste à son rival
socialiste mais l'hypothèse d'une telle
alliance inquiète les francophones celle
ci se porte vraiment les francophones ne
parviennent pas bien négocié parce que
d'abord nous sommes moins nombreux parce
que nous avons moins d'argent et donc
nous lâcheront elio di rupo est sans
doute le leader francophone le mieux
disposé à faire un pas en avant vers une
belgique confédérale
mais lors de sa rencontre avec le roi
albert ii il a tout de même posé ses
conditions
bref les négociations pour la formation
d'un nouveau gouvernement seront sans
doute les plus difficiles de toute
l'histoire du pays
elle risque fort de ne pas être terminé
avant le 1er juillet
date à laquelle la belgique prendra la
tête de l'union européenne dans ce cas
c'est yves leterme le premier ministre
démissionnaire qui assurerait les
affaires courantes
un scénario inquiétant en pleine crise
de l'euro et nous sommes à strasbourg
avec deux invités jean pierre audy vont
vous êtes le patron ici des eurodéputés
français du groupe ppe le parti
populaire européen majoritaire est à vos
côtés
votre collègue député belge et membre du
parti socialiste européen marc tarabella
bonjour à vous alors les cassandres un
peu partout en europe prédisent déjà la
fin de la belgique après la victoire des
nationalistes flamands du nva qui
prônent eux ouvertement la disparition
du pays faut-il les croire
je crois pas qu'il faut croire les
cassandre en effet les élections
dimanche auront été très clair elles ont
privilégié en francs en flandre
quelqu'un comme bart de wever et la nva
qui réalise un score remarquable et donc
est un nationaliste qui bien sûr prône
dans son discours qu'il veut aller vers
une fin de la belgique mais ils veulent
surtout et il a recueilli un grand
succès parce qu'il prône un état
évolutif la belgique dans l'état fédéral
qui a privilégié un pouvoir décentralisé
vers les régions dès les années 80 dès
les années 70 dans la loi et aujourd'hui
ils veulent un fédéralisme plus aboutie
avec plus de pouvoirs aux régions et au
sud du pays ont une victoire socialiste
qui est une victoire aussi de rempart
contre la crise etc mais qui fait en
sorte qu'aujourd'hui il y a deux grands
acteurs ça vient d'être dit dans le
reportage bart de wever elio di rupo qui
se sont vu d'ailleurs il y à il ya
quelques quelques jours et qui ont
commencé à négocier ensemble
alors marc tarabella votre collègue des
verts daniel cohn bendit a parlé pour
qualifier ce vote d'un repli identitaire
et conservateurs vous lui avez répondu
assez vertement oui daniel cohn bendit
ça fait 42 ans qui s'exprime
il ne dit pas toujours
des choses sensées et donc c'est bien de
lui rentrer un petit peu dedans quand il
dit n'importe quoi qu'un verre considère
qu'une victoire socialiste
ce quelqu'un en wallonie ni victoire
presque historique et une victoire
conservatrice ça vient d'un verre je
peux comprendre que ça les dérange un
petit peu politiquement
en tout cas c'est une victoire
progressiste en wallonie donc c'est pour
ça que je lui suis gelé évidemment plus
que titiller là dessus et clairement en
flandre je dirais que c'est une victoire
nationaliste parce que peut-être on n'a
pas résolu les problèmes au niveau de
l'arrondissement de
bruxelles-hal-vilvorde est symptomatique
on ne l'a pas résolu dans le passé et il
est grand temps aujourd'hui et tout le
monde en est conscient qu'il faut régler
ce problème pour encore avancer ensemble
dans je dirais les problèmes qui
concernent les gens qui sont davantage
de socio économique alors vous même jean
pierre audy comment vous voyez certes
ces élections en belgique c'est cette
crise ouverte est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un vote identitaire vous y voyez
un peu un repli communautariste
en tant qu'homme politique française je
n'ai pas à m'immiscer dans le
fonctionnement d'un état membre
le problème le problème de la wallonie
et de la france de la flandre est un
problème belge c'est un problème
européen ce qui pourrait devenir un
problème européen
c'est l'examen de la respiration de nos
frontières intérieures parle beaucoup
des frontières extérieures de l'union
mais si on regarde depuis la chute du
mur de berlin l'allemagne s'est
réunifiée la tchécoslovaquie s'est
séparé dans les balkans les frontières
on voit la naissance d'état comme le
kosovo même s'ils sont pas des états
membres mais c'est le continent européen
je discute parfois avec mes amis anglais
qui m'explique que s'il y avait un
référendum d'autodétermination de
l'ecosse le royaume uni ferait
probablement une grave erreur mais là
aussi par des mouvements je vais très
souvent le catalogue ou un élu
socialiste catalan me disais si l'union
européenne pouvait nous aider
la catalogne à devenir une nation ai je
répondu mais la catalogne c'est un
problème espagnol c'est un peu le mot
puisque l'europe d'après toi et gagner
en france renforçant au niveau des états
l'europe connaissait ces logiques de
l'europe l'euro l'un est un instrument
de moyens au service des états membres
l'europe ne se construira pas contre les
états membres l'union européenne n'a
rien à faire à ce mail et je dirais de
ce qui relève de la souveraineté des
peuples
est-ce qu'il faut pas faire l'europe des
régions marc tarabella moi j'ai très
peur de l'europe des régions parce que
ceux qui ont des velléités d'autonomie
aujourd'hui on parle de la catalogne on
peut parler de la flandre par exemple il
ya des sablons c'est la même logique
quand même la ligue lombarde la ligue du
nord l'italie ça ce sont de vrais
xénophobe devrait repli sur soi est très
identitaire finalement je ne mentirai
pas l'europe des riches dont l'europe
des pauvres qu'ils veulent
et donc j'ai très peur de ça je préfère
l'europe des états qu'ils soient
solidaires et d'ailleurs si on en parle
si on parle la gouvernance économique
avoir une gouvernance économique fort
pour pouvoir mieux résisté face aux
crises sens aux attaques extérieures des
spéculateurs c'est cette europe là qu'il
faut une europe plus aboutie encore plus
fédéraliste et je la vois davantage sur
les états que sont les régions
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que ce qui
se passe en belgique c'est quand même
aussi un peu ça illustre et du triomphe
des égoïsmes et chacun pour soi dans une
europe où par exemple les flamands ne
veulent pas forcément payer pour les
pour les wallons de même que par exemple
les allemands ne veulent plus payer pour
les grecs une rampe où il aurait
peut-être un manque de solidarité
je peux partager solide la belgique est
peut-être un microcosme de l'europe où
finalement le compromis a toujours été
la voie de la solution n'ya jamais à 2 à
une exception près en 1950 pour la
question royale après la guerre les gens
mais le sang n'a jamais coulé en
belgique
on parlait la tchécoslovaquie jean
perrault libre et un gecko slovaquie
c'est ce qu'on appelle la révolution de
velours en belgique on en est pas là
mais il ya toujours eu un compromis qui
a prévalu comment l'europe
on a toujours je démens les sommes
toujours sortis vainqueurs des
situations difficiles par la solidarité
la compréhension et surtout le compromis
et je pense que autre en belgique qu'au
niveau européen c'est vers ça qu'il faut
aller et la belgique aujourd'hui dans
une situation un peu délicate c'est vrai
surtout qu'elle va aborder la présidence
européenne
mais il faut surmonter cela je pense que
là il faut savoir s'écouter les uns les
autres pour arriver à un accord qui
finalement satisfasse les deux parties
en belgique oui la belgique va prendre
la présidence de l'union européenne au
1er juillet c'est à dire très bientôt
sans forcément avoir de gouvernement qui
va présider l'europe vous êtes vous êtes
inquiet jean perrault dit pas outre
mesure ce sont des cas de figure que
nous avons déjà vu dans le passé lorsque
le gouvernement tchèque est tombé il
assurait la présidence dont
l'enseignement qu'il faut tirer ce qu'il
faut faire disparaître cette présence
pendant qu'ils présentent aucun intérêt
aujourd'hui il faut consolider un
exécutif politique c'est monsieur
vendront de paulhe dont je regrette
qu'ils ne viennent pas chercher au sein
du parlement européen
sa légitimité et il faut le plus
rapidement possible faire supprimer ce
présent tournant alors monsieur vendre
un peu inquiets tentent de mettre en
place avec ses partenaires le
gouvernement le fameux gouvernement
économique européen dont on a parlé à
l'instant l'idée progresse en europe
c'est à la une de ce tour d'europe
réalisé par nora à malice
après un report surprise de leur
entrevue en gueule à merkel et nicolas
sarkozy ont réussi à accoucher d'un
projet commun un projet qui reprend en
majeure partie la position de la
chancelière
le projet est simple la mise en place
d'un gouvernement économique à 27 et non
de la zone euro seule et ce sans créer
de nouvelles institutions
paris souhaitait pourtant la création
d'un secrétariat économique
autres annonces fracassantes la
proposition d'une taxe sur les
transactions financières lors du
prochain g20 une taxe qui pourrait
rapporter 20 milliards d'euros de
recettes potentielles en europe selon la
commission en retour berlin a accepté un
plan de sauvetage de l'euro si
nécessaire mais a exigé la mise en
oeuvre de sanctions pour les pays
laxistes qui laisseraient filer leurs
déficits
en l'occurrence une privation de leurs
droits de vote et c'est justement les
déficits qui nourrissent les inquiétudes
de bruxelles les rumeurs se font plus qu
insistantes concernant l'espagne qui
après athènes serait le deuxième pays
d'europe à demander l'aide de l'union
une rumeur une nouvelle fois démenti par
madrid
plus largement la commission a de
nouveau pointé du doigt les déficits
excessifs notamment de la france dont
elle attend des efforts budgétaires
supplémentaires drapeau vert prête pour
les vacances comme chaque année le
satisfecit délivré par la commission et
l'agencé européenne de l'environnement
récompense les qualité des eaux de
baignade en europe
verdict 96% des zones côtières et 90 %
des aux intérieurs sont conformes aux
normes en légère baisse néanmoins par
rapport à l'année dernière
en france on compte environ 2000 plages
non conformes en italie plus de 5000
mais ce sont les deux pays qui compte le
plus de littoral
alors une question à vous peut-être jean
perrault dit nicolas sarkozy s'est
finalement rallié à l'idée d'un gala
merkel d'instaurer un gouvernement
économique au niveau des des 27 états
membres alors qu'il souhaitait que cela
se fasse au niveau des seize de la zone
euro ce qui n'a pas lâché face à la
chancellière allemande
non c'est pas tout à fait ça l'idée d'un
gouvernement économique est une très
ancienne idée qui a d'ailleurs proposé
lorsque nous avons créé l'union
économique et monétaire et nicolas
sarkozy lorsqu'il a présidé l'union
européenne au deuxième semestre 2008 art
proposé cette idée de gouvernement
économique de l'union européenne
mais bien sûr au niveau de la zone euro
dès 16h au niveau de l'union européenne
deuxième semestre 2008 ensuite il y a eu
le problème de stabilité de la monnaie
est bien sûr que s'agissant de la
stabilité de la monnaie c'est les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de la zone
euro qui agissent mais sur l'aspect
croissance économique c'est toujours
cette idée
donc c'est un compromis franco-allemand
qui est d'excellente qualité
comme vous voyez ce compromis est ce que
quelle est la bonne formule pour ce
fameux gouvernement économique de
l'europe attend depuis de nombreuses
années c'est en tout cas un pas décisif
dans la bonne direction parce que quand
on considère que la crise nous a frappés
et qu'on a chacun essaie d'apporter des
morceaux de solutions dans chacun de nos
états membres
on appelait je ferrais de nos voeux nous
les fédéralistes européens quel que soit
notre bord politique à ce qui est plus
de gouvernance européenne pour plus
d'efficacité la crise au niveau de la
grèce en est aussi un autre exemple avec
finalement des positions différentes
dans les états membres qui font qu'on
n'a pas répondu tout de suite et qu'on a
fait le jeu des spéculateurs qui ne sont
jamais que des criminels en col blanc
qui profite d'une situation de faiblesse
et qui spéculent sont des états membres
et leurs faiblesses et sur leur la
pauvreté de leurs citoyens s'y est très
grave donc aujourd'hui on a besoin cette
gouvernance économique européenne pour
aller de l'avant
la taxe sur les transactions financières
je suis étonné du chiffre annoncé par la
commission parce que les chiffres que
des spécialistes économiques m'ont
fourni une taxe de 0 à 0 25% au 0-0 25%
produirait l'équivalent du budget
européen annuel en europe c'est à dire à
peu près 135 milliards d'euros donc
clairement forêts y est aussi décider
seul colon faire avec ce produit de la
taxe mais ce serait idéal de pouvoir le
faire au niveau européen européens dans
un consensus à 27 pays
est ce que vous pensez qu'une
excursion européenne est vraiment
efficace alors que des institutions les
institutions financières ne ne
connaissent pas forcément de frontières
est ce que ce serait vraiment efficace
j'interdis la question des ressources
propres et posé pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas la solution mais sur
gouvernement économique c'est capital de
le faire l'échelle de l'union parce
qu'il ya un point sur très important
s'est il faudra ce gouvernement
économique une dimension parlementaire
pour la dimension parlementaire à
l'échelle de la zone euro on ne sait pas
faire donc la dimension parlementaire en
alliance avec les parlements nationaux
pour que parlement européen et
parlements nationaux ne puissions avoir
des grands débats d'orientations
économiques financières et budgétaires
sur le fonctionnement du continent pour
à la fois faire des économies sur le
fonctionnement de la sphère publique
union européenne et états membres et
également vers des grands plans
d'investissement sur notre continent ça
c'est capital merci beaucoup monsieur
d'avoir participé à ce débat d' europe
hebdo est ce que vous aimez le gruyère
mais aussi les fromages d'auvergne sont
excellentes mons et les pois ce que je
préfère c'est bourguignon je sais alors
on va rejoindre tout de suite olivier
picard et ses invités qui nous parle du
gourou hier à opter regarder le gruyère
peut-il se fondre dans la réforme qui
d'ici 2012 va faire disparaître les aoc
appellation d'origine contrôlée pour
laisser place à un nouveau label
européen les aop appellation d'origine
protégée
eh bien ce n'est pas évident quand des
territoires sont en concurrence de part
et d'autre des frontières pour
l'exclusivité du produit alors le
gruyère écartelée entre la suisse et la
france 7 à reportage de florence maurice
et flora sauvage dans une exploitation
franc comtoise qui risque de perdre sa
mise dans cette affaire
vous désirez messieurs dames vous avez
le beaufort aoc l'emmental grands crus
les gruyère aoc aoc appellation
d'origine contrôlée
le logo roi des fromageries française en
2007 ici en franche comté c'est le
gruyère qui a rejoint ce club très privé
mais désormais pour continuer à être
utilisés les appellations doivent être
reconnus par l'europe est transformé en
aop appellation d'origine protégée
depuis des mois les producteurs de
gruyère sont suspendus au verdict de
l'europe et les chevaliers travaille
chez un grand affineur ce matin il
découvre le dernier avis du commissaire
européen à l'agriculture
cet avis tombe comme un couperet c'est
un courrier donc de dassier en solo ski
qui s'adressait au ministre de
l'agriculture
donc pour donner un avis on va dire
qu'il n'est pas favorable pour notre
demande d'art au pays pour le dossier
une cuillère aoc france
à défaut d'une initiative de votre part
la procédure visant le rejet formel de
la demande d'inclusion de la
dénomination gruyère en tant qu
appellation d'origine protégée ne pourra
être que poursuivi nous annonce déjà que
la bataille est perdue donc faut-il
engagé la bataille quitte à tout perdre
tout perdre car sans cette
reconnaissance européenne
c'est toute la jeune filière du gruyère
qui est menacé comme des dizaines de
paysans eric avait choisi de se
reconvertir dans la production de lait
aoc en 2007 derrière difficile
d'affaires avec des bâches de pays
nourriture deux fois pas bougé m
la hausse est certes un cahier des
charges exigeant mais à la clé pour guy
c'était la garantie de stabiliser ses
revenus une aubaine en pleine crise du
lait en europe aussi et par rapport aux
autres produits
c'est que on se met d'accord sur un prix
au début de l'année un prix à peu près
identique tournée qui est complètement
déconnecté de lait standard le standard
c'est un mec qui est l'aîné ou marché
300 dans le sud
j avais même agrandi son troupeau et
embaucher son fils dans la ferme
aujourd'hui il s'inquiète pour son
avenir ça fait deux ans qu'on est con en
gruyère aoc où on était sûr que ça
allait normalement passer un aute
puisque et au bout de deux ans on ne
dîne un problème
l'europe ne accepte pas là au pays je
suis pas comment on va continuer pour
que ce soit trop tard de quoi
chaque jour le lait de guy parent dans
cette coopérative pour être transformé
en fromage
ici aussi on a investi dans le gruyère
aoc 300000 euros en deux ans sans la
transformation de cette aoc en aop
n'importe qui en europe pourraient se
mettre à fabriquer du gruyère une perte
économique et historique pour le
président de cette coopérative
nous ce qui nous intéresse au niveau du
produit c'est d'avoir une protection
c'est à dire que le mot gruyère ne soit
pas galvaudé et que quel que ce soit
puisse faire du gruyère demain donc un
cahier des charges est strict et une
zone réservée ou le gruyère ne pourra se
faire que dans cette zone à problèmes
pour l'europe une fois fabriquée ici les
fromages sont transportés à 150 km pour
la dernière étape de leur fabrication
l'affinage les moules ont été
réceptionnés elles sont parties des
fromageries
elle arrive ici donc angoisse état de
caillebotte en fait c'est un fromage en
blanc puis qui n'a pas de goût on va
dire on n'a pas fait développer de son
potentiel
or pour la commission européenne sans
une unité entre zones de production et
zone d'affinage impossible de délivrer
son précieux label à l'inao qui a
accordé la hausse et au gruyère et
défend désormais le dossier auprès de la
commission on considère que c'est une
mauvaise interprétation
et on met en avant des raisons
historiques les affineurs se sont
toujours installés dans des plaines ou
en tout cas à proximité de grands axes
de communication puisque ce sont eux les
affineurs qui ensuite commercialiser les
fromages
donc il est assez normal dans une
appellation entre mager surtout de
montagne d'avoir des zones qui petit à
petit se sont spécialisés soit pour la
production du lait soit pour la finale
cette culture il faut qu'on arrive à la
partager avec tous les pays d'europe
pour qu'ils comprennent le pourquoi on
s'évertue à mettre en avant nos atouts p
aujourd'hui l'europe conseil à la france
d'abandonner la houppe et au profit de
lits gp encore une autre appellation qui
permet certes de protéger le mot gruyère
mais restent totalement inconnues du
grand public
alors avec nous pour parler de cette
évolution à josé bové député européen
vert qu'on ne plaisante com présente
qu'on ne présente plus excuser moi alors
pour commencer josé bové est ce que
cette harmonisation du label européen
dao severa au pl et pertinente est ce
que c'est une bonne chose pour les
producteurs comme pour le produit dont
je crois que c'est une bonne chose parce
que quand on connaît les aoc d'où elles
sont parties elle était quand même la
plupart du temps aux mains des
transformateurs et en fait les
producteurs avaient un pouvoir mais on
identifié par le produit avec un cahier
des charges très important au niveau
production de la matière première
aujourd'hui un rééquilibrage dans le
cadre de la op beaucoup plus cohérente
un territoire un mode de production pour
la transformer pour la production du
lait et la transformation en produit
final est là aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus cohérent il ya un meilleur
équilibre donc moi je pense que cette
évolution vers la op est quelque chose
qui a renforcé ce signe de qualité par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu il ya 80 ans
50 ans et où les dernières années alors
quand on voit la compétition entre le
gruyère suisse et brière français pour
l'exclusivité finalement de la op est-ce
qu'il va falloir choisir entre le
territoire et le produit laser c'est un
débat un peu compliqué parce qu'on voit
bien que la vraie question la scène
question d'affinage le mode de
production il ya un cahier des charges
qui est strict le produit final
il est produit avec aussi des techniques
bien approprié le problème c
distance par rapport à la finale moi je
me demande dans quelle mesure la au 6
mai les affineurs en même temps les
grands groupes parce qu'il ya des grands
groupes dont on voit le nom apparaître
comme dans le reportage ne pourrait pas
aussi faire un effort parce que c'est
l'intérêt général de la collectivité de
rapprocher aussi le lieu de la finale
donc évidemment ça va nécessiter des
investissements mais je pense que le jeu
en vaut la chandelle
dans ces cas là les pouvoirs publics
doivent accompagner la mise en
application de nouveaux outils
d'affinage près de la zone de production
mais là dessus est ce que les règles
européennes
pour être plus clair est-ce que le
parlement précisément peut aider
l'europe à éviter ce qu'on a vu dans le
reportage dé confusion notamment
d'interprétation de la règle c'est
toujours le problème qu'on a c'est à
dire que l'europe va fixer un cadre de
la op mais ensuite il y a dans chaque
pays des instituts nationaux et des
syndicats d'appellation locaux une aop à
son organisation locale d'accord entre
producteurs et transformateurs c'est là
où se fixe la règle du jeu et il ya un
comité de surveillance qui est vérifiée
avec des représentants d'autres aop que
les règles sont bien respectés qu'on va
dans le bon sens donc c'est à ce niveau
là que se définissent les règles réel
mais c'est vrai que le principe d'un
territoire qui soit cohérent pour
produire et transformé et affiné est une
règle qui est une règle de bon sens qui
permet d'empêcher qu'une aop se
transforme en sous-produits industriels
alors il ya des producteurs qui sont un
peu perdus justement dans l'évolution
administratif que suppose justement
cette réforme on écoute la question d'un
président de coopérative eelv où la
pause à vous
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
comment protéger les productions qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas sous signe de
qualité qui existaient mais qu' on ne
peut pas supporter la concurrence de
produits beaucoup plus industrielles et
qui font la diversité de nos productions
aujourd'hui alors pour celles qui n'ont
pas un label au départ de qualité qu'est
ce qu'on fait mais moi je pense qu'il
faut voir déjà si on a une spécificité
si on a une spécificité on peut aussi
enclencher le processus
dao paix parce que c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut toujours faire évoluer on
peut mettre en avant de nouvelles âmes
op alors c'est vrai que c'est un
processus qui est lent moi je pense que
c'est important de le faire je trouve
que aujourd'hui c'est un des signes qui
permet d'identifier une région en même
temps il ya un autre signe qui est très
important qui est le signe agriculture
biologique qui est bien connu des
consommateurs parce que c'est celui qui
définit le mieux la la qualité le mode
de production
moi je pense il vous qu'on renforce
aujourd'hui la op pour qu'on en dise
hi-fi à la fois le lieu d'où ça vient et
la façon dont le lait produit ou dont la
transformation est fait pour ce pour ces
produits là moi je pense qu'il faut
d'abord faire un vrai travail de
connaissance et de se rendre compte dans
réunissant tous les acteurs
si on peut avoir quelques cahiers des
charges n'a alors je pense que ça vaut
le coup de se lancer dans le dossier de
la reconnaissance si on est sur un
processus il a malheureusement on a le
mérite au podium coopérative n'a pas dit
ce qu'il faisait mais on leur propose
quelques fois le label ea gp indications
géographiques de provenance de
provenance est-ce que ça c'est un
déclassement c'est ressenti comme un
déclassement par les producteurs
le problème c'est que c'est un signe qui
est un petit peu ambigu moi je suis un
petit peu mal à l'aise avec les gp parce
que ça donne effectivement souvent le
nom d'un produit final mais dont la
matière première peut venir d'un rayon
beaucoup plus large
alors je vais pas citer des noms mais il
ya un jambon célèbre du sud ouest de la
france dont on peut ramasser les
les ports jusqu en poitou charentes est
ce que ça vient vraiment un lien avec la
frontière espagnole gens n'en suis pas
vraiment sûr donc parfois les gps a fait
un bon coup de pub mais en même temps ça
n'ancrent pas le produit localement et
surtout ça permet pas aux producteurs de
se défendre dans dans une
interprofession où on organise la
maîtrise des volumes avec la fixation
des prix parce que c'est bien ça
qu'attendent aujourd'hui des producteurs
c'est à travers les signes de qualité de
pour avoir la garantie d'un revenu
stable qui couvrent leurs coûts parce
qu'il ya un cahier des charges ya une
légitimité à ce que ce produit soit
payer plus cher par les transformateurs
et 7 igps qu'on peut faire un effort
justement pour mieux l'informer ce que
personne ne le connaît ce label est ce
que ça vaut le coup justement de faire
une campagne justement de vulgarisation
l'igpn
ou est ce que c'est une fausse piste moi
je pense qu'il faut d'abord vraiment
fait une vraie campagne sur les aop
qu'on ait une campagne solis gp je suis
d'accord mais il faut surtout faire
attention qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion
dans la dans la tête du consommateur
parce qu'effectivement on n'est pas sur
la même précision de lieux de production
et de cahiers des charges de
transformation en place je crois qu'il
faut faire très attention parce qu'on
vous derrière cela il ya un certain
nombre d'industriels qui aimerait bien
faire un amalgame entre les i gp les aop
ya eu des tentatives quand il ya eu le
rapport ce quota qui a été débattue au
parlement d'essayer de partir vers une
politique des marques qui deviennent qui
remplacerait les signes de qualité
d'accord et josé bové merci le clin
d'oeil de cette semaine c'est le
brussels film festival du 23 au 30 juin
prochain alors en avant première la
meute avec benjamin biolay et emilie
dequenne un couple d'acteurs européens
les mecs c'est franchement lui avec vous
mais nos pitt a rendez vous avec le cul
de la petite là j'ai pas trop envie la
faire attendre voici bazooka joe et de
la cedh jeunes de 18 et jordan minnesota
on peut joindre avant ted en chine
une haleine à faire cailler les yaourts
chéri non plus je n'aime pas la musique
le festival du film de bruxelles c'est
jusqu'au 30 juin en attendant il est
temps de refermer la page de cette
émission et la semaine prochaine nous
serons justement à bruxelles très bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
vouvry
a man à bruxelles très bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires